How has being a daddy changed you though?
It's changed everything about me.
Tell me how?
I mean, the simple value of life changes when you have something to live for.
When you have something to look forward to,...
Ok.
...you know, your standard of living changes....
...to understand love in a way that is unconditional.
You know, to be able to look at something so passionately and give all of yourself to make sure that...
...it is protected, it is the greatest that it can be,...
...not sheltered but protected.
It's something that I've never felt before.
Right.
You know, I'd say, I felt some of that maybe in marriage but for the most part,...
...the one thing that is irreplaceable and unconditional...
...is that love and passion that I have for my children.
Got you.
My boys.
Yes, you mentioned your marriage, we won't talk about it long.
But, you know, we all know that you decided to part ways.
Yeah.
You guys are still raising your family together?
Do you see yourself ever becoming a married man again in the industry?
You mean in the industry?
Well, Usher Raymond, do you see yourself getting married again?
I mean, I can't say never, forever.
Right.
But right now, that's not really my focus.
You know, one thing I will say is that having been married...
...and have such an incredible moment happen in my life,...
...I'd never demean what that is and how incredible that moment is, or would be.
You know, to be able to have it with the right person is important.
Right.
Unfortunately, we didn't work out in that way.
But as I said, never to demean what it meant to me and how genuine of the moment.
It was genuine.
One of the most genuine moments of my life, definitely.
Definitely.